[Music]
vaynernation what is good uh super
excited to be here
uh this is
i actually am gonna have to edit this
for some social media content because
the two of us have done wine content
before
many many many moons ago
when uh when kevin was the king of web
2.0 with dig.com
the amazing
wonderful
profound kevin rose is with us and and
is now the king of web three i mean moon
birds is a [ __ ] beast i want to talk
about that and i also want to kind of
execute on this little mini thing i've
been doing
called the empathy chats um is that the
official word yeah beautiful the empathy
hour which is always done within a half
an hour which is my favorite part of the
whole concept um where we taste a little
empathy wine we talk about
emotional intelligence and i think when
i think about kevin
i actually am going to go into a place
of asking him he was such a young kid
when he was running such a big company
many years ago he's
now at the helm of the
big company because that's just what
happens i've lived a year ago with to be
friends you kind of have these hopes and
ambitions to be creative and then
there's actual real revenue and
responsibilities and you got to build
something so first of all kevin thank
you for being on the show oh brother
good to see you such an inspiration for
all that i do so it's good to be here
with you
kev
let's go into the subject matter here
we'll get into some of the other stuff
the the reason i want to do this mini
thing is a
you know help john and nate
constellation team promote a little
empathy wines empathywines.com go check
it out but b
really you know after writing 12 and a
half i wrote it during covid
you know i really got into my feelings
of what kind of leader i am
like why things work for me why it's
sustainable this will actually make
sense to you because i think you know i
you're one truly one of my only friends
like actual friends i made like i make
queens out the ass i even make
lightweight friends but like friend
friend like you know and i think one
thing that
i always loved about you is i find you
incredibly compassionate
like if i had a compassionate cabernet i
would have been pouring that right now
thank you and what i mean by that is i
could actually sense
we've never talked about this i could
but i'm happy to say this out loud
because it just shows what kind of human
being you are i could actually sense
as i was starting to ascend up
in the web 2 world 2000 not 2009 anymore
not more like 2011 but in like 2013 14
when it was like
cut i could actually sense from you
the most wonderful feeling which was i
felt you were concerned for me
if i was gonna burn out die of a heart
attack like you know like you would you
know we you know you and i are similar
and different
we have some similarities with content
and
but in real life you have a lot more
introverted aspects you keep it a little
bit tighter
and you know when we would be out at
events and things that made i would just
like go into the tornado and like kiss
every baby and write and i could
actually send i we never ever had this
combo
something that made me fall in love with
you even more
was it was so nice to be cared for i
could sense your concern
i remember when we went to have dinner
at hearth restaurant oh yeah yeah and
you had asked if the camera crew could
come long
and i said no
and it wasn't because i mean you were
you did good news good news i like i
surely would love that because by the
way mistake because i wish we could
watch that video right now
because that's a little bit part of this
that people miss but
but oh i forgot about this dinner go
ahead i don't want to cut you up i just
i just wanted to get the you know i
wanted to have that that one-on-one time
you know just get like like let's turn
the cameras off and just see how you're
feeling how you hold it because you were
i mean dude i remember when we left that
restaurant
we couldn't walk like five feet without
people being like
and i'm sure that's still the case today
obviously and it's just like but i want
to make sure like things were good you
know it's um so let's talk about that
we'll check in you're you're the best
dude i know that that's why i've always
cherished this friendship
that's different because that's a
friendship
tell me what you did well
and what you didn't do well
running dig
paint the pictures for everybody you
were super young
yeah for you were literally the poster
child for web 2 because of that business
was it business week or i don't remember
what was the money yeah business week
put me on the cover um about a year into
our i was doing it and then it was i
mean you've been through this before as
well like then it was ink magazine then
i was on jimmy fallon twice but
by the way fallon's
moon birds post today got me fired up
i literally touched him right away i'm
like yes so no but
that moment
was the you know there's these
quintessential moments ashton
challenging cnn to a million
uh dj khaled for snapchat
you know kind of the i would call it
like a charlie dimlio thing for
tick-tock there's these moments and
much of what i'm concerned about with
nfts and web 3 of like a crash that
happened with web stocks
and then the and then like the roses
from the concrete were built
for the you know the slash dots and you
know the meta build like the thing
amazon.com ebay paypal all those were
web one didn't know if they were gonna
make it and then eventually they got
built up and they made it yeah but you
and dig represented things that were
built from the concrete of the carnage
of the internet stock bubble
right and really be represented for me
that like it was such a big deal
um
how old were you when you were on the
cover of that magazine
oh gosh i don't know about late 20s so i
was
i was thinking was my late 20s because
i'm in my mid 40s now so so late 20s how
old was big was one year right
yeah about that about one year and what
happened you guys took you raised some
capital and that's what i remember there
was a big number on at the time now that
it's like small enough yeah
don't be humble please because we're
painting a picture what did the cover
actually say because i know you know it
um it said something like how this kid
made 60 million dollars in six months or
something like that which wasn't true
because that was the evaluation yeah
they always i mean this [ __ ] happens to
me all the time like but
but the headline doesn't actually match
the truth but
that was
what what was that kevin in his late 20s
that's a lot to handle all the instant
internet theme which was still different
back then
we're single
you were running a company for the first
time of this size there was lots of
things that happened like
being single was probably the best part
of what could have happened during that
time
but in terms of all the other stuff
it was like
we laughed because we both know you were
with me
you know like um so what what
what was the what what do you think you
did well
that you want to bring to the table
with this new venture i didn't know
really well i mean what it was is that
here's the deal this is the the real
talk the real talk was that
i was a college dropout
and
um
i just didn't have a brain for
school in that capacity like i i just
i've had a really hard time memorizing
things and when you're talking about
school that was always difficult for me
like i i couldn't tell you where certain
letters of the alphabet would fall like
on the of the spectrum on the a to z
like it there was really things that you
know but other kids
you got reading comprehension stuff
yeah it was like in retention it was
like i i could read something and i
would forget it immediately
by the way to this day i you know i mean
you've seen me right i mean
yeah that's horrible
like
this is how i know i'm getting a real
email from gary it's like when i see it
i'm like oh yeah gary wrote that email
okay that's not that's not his
insistence yeah exactly um the i totally
get it so you go ahead keep saying you
weren't there yeah so so so basically i
was bad at that i you know i i loved
computers so i got in that i studied
computer science it was frank quite
frankly it was too hard for me i dropped
out but i loved product i loved building
and i loved ideation and dreaming up new
ideas and just thinking of what could
possibly be and we should probably go
build this so that meant
i worked with a lot of contractors and i
was just trying to find people that
would help me build these ideas that i
had now the issue
you know is i always had this kind of
like hidden thing behind me that was
always fearful that someone would
discover
my my faults my internal things that i
was carrying around with me and so i was
afraid to ask for help
so there were so many times when i
didn't know the answer for something and
i just didn't i didn't want to raise my
hand and be like hey investor hey mentor
or like i'd like if i ask this dumb
question they'll immediately look down
on me and i didn't realize that that's
right
you didn't realize humility was a
strength not a weakness right and
admitting that you're wrong or that you
don't know something is the only way you
can actually grow i had a very different
thing i would be able to figure out
things in a meeting that i didn't know
in the beginning
so i wouldn't ask
for clarity on things i didn't know
because i knew how to get to the answer
through a series of statements and
questions along the way that were
different interesting and then when i be
when i really started getting into
myself the last five years as a better
leader than i've ever been
i realized that i was at a different
place in my career where me saying what
is those
basic acronyms what does that mean
would resonate so heavily with the 12
kids in the room
that i could change the culture of
vayner to be
based on humility as a superpower by me
leading the way with like hey client
what did that acronym mean and i i
went away from a greek a fun strength
which was i could still figure it out it
was like profoundly like cool for me i'm
like wow that's cool like that's how my
brain works
uh to something that's even better the
humility like you know like i don't have
to challenge myself to figure it out
like you get the answer and
more importantly inspired people to lean
into humility yeah absolutely it's huge
once you once you that you finally that
that sticks with you and you're not
afraid it's a big
unlock one thing that i think you
probably struggled with that i struggled
with
to this day which always blows people's
mind
because i'm so candarous on stage and as
garyvee
my assumption because i was close enough
to you was it was incredibly hard for
you to have the tough conversation with
any employee at dig that they sucked or
they needed to be fired because they
were all your friends
or if nothing else even when the company
got bigger you were kevin the awesome
dude is that true
it is absolutely true i think there
there's a couple things there one i
didn't know how to properly evaluate
like new incoming talent and do the you
know require due diligence to figure out
whether or not they were actually really
good at what they claimed to be good at
um and then the second piece was i want
to stop you real quick huge superpower
of yours and i share it and i don't want
to take this away from people
what kevin said there was profound comma
don't underestimate the power
of blind optimism
you know we can sit here and talk about
all the clunkers that happened because
ricky told you they were great and
you're like ricky you're my guy let's
get a beer afterwards and but you would
have missed a lot of greatness too if
you went too logical too i'm always
scared that we're mature now and missing
magic
mm-hmm that's a great point right yeah
absolutely yeah
so uh what was the second piece of that
so oh the other hard piece is that i was
one that avoided conflict my dad was a
very uh verbally aggressive um person to
the family but more so to my mom
and so you know he would um there almost
wasn't a night in my childhood where he
wasn't in a yelling screaming battle and
my mom wouldn't fight back she was just
like the the receiver of that
and so i grew up um not wanting to be
like dad you know and just being wanting
to be the opposite so i avoided conflict
at all costs
and so it was really hard my dad didn't
do that to my mom but he did it to his
employees
which is why i think i'm the most pro
employee
communicating entrepreneurs for the
world yeah
yeah so i mean my dad's
kev i drove 45 minutes from my parents
house to wine library where we did our
show not that one it was a smaller store
at the time at 14 years old my dad did
not say a single word to me the whole
ride dead silence we pull up to the
store
and he goes turns to me and he goes keep
it on the keep an eye on the employees
they want to steal
that was the only thing
so i'm very that i can really resonate
with that
yeah
yeah my dad's my dad's the best
like got real he was tough on the
outside because he was so soft on the
inside i'm like the reverse i'm so soft
on the outside because i'm tough as [ __ ]
on the inside
isn't it funny how when you when you
evaluate your parents for me you know
with my dad
he was like the best dad in terms of
like taking me outside throwing around
the football like you know taking me to
boy scout meetings like things like that
checked all those boxes for me but then
was a terrible husband
and so you know it's my job in going
forward to pick the best attributes that
i can look at and say
those are amazing i'm going to carry
those forward in my life going forward
and here's all the crap that dad no
thanks like my dad my dad since passed
away but i can let that go now and say
that that stays with you you know like i
i and i i'm freeing up my kids
from having to have that that pain and
in a sense kind of freeing him up as
well because that the pain doesn't
continue on through me you know
i mean that's an incredibly
like
i wanted this blog series to be really
focused on business of emotions and
business
like you know you know that i am an
uncomfortable cheerleader of you
publicly forever and i always appreciate
that man and this has been
such a profoundly emotional week for me
because i feel like you're getting a lot
of just credit this week from this new
world and it makes me happy not that you
need it because i know you too well you
don't need it um it just makes me happy
like this weekend
when moon birds went bananas of course
people that haven't been paying
attention are going to have a natural
reaction
no different than everybody has a
natural reaction when they see something
explode to that level so fast
and you know obviously the conversation
plays out on twitter and discord and
being able to jump into a couple of
random conversations
and
saying kevin told me about crypto pucks
kevin this ryan carson gave me my first
speaking engagement like has been just
so enjoyable
and
and the way you just described what you
described which i believe you just
articulated
personal beliefs one man's point of view
single
greatest responsibility of a human being
i believe the singular
responsibility of a human being
back to parents being such a framework
of actual life
is to focus on the good
that your parents brought to the table
carry it on to your children
forgive
the bad that your parents brought to the
table because oh by the way they had a
parent
and for the ones unlike me because i
didn't know every i got lucky my
problems my problems were micro with my
dad but they were real because we worked
together
the great fortune in my life was the
only grandparent i knew
was the grandparent that parented my
father
me knowing my mom my father's mom for my
whole life
was the greatest gift that god ever gave
me
because i was able to understand my
father's shortcomings because my
grandmother was so profoundly in my life
she would come on my mom's birthday on
may 3rd to our house and she would leave
september 10th
on my dad's birthday so she lived with
us almost half the year
she and then by the way i knew her
mother which is [ __ ] completely
insane i knew my great grandmother's
super well we immigrated from america
and she died when i was 14 so i really
knew her too
um
i think i'm i talk about the [ __ ] that i
talk about so much because i understood
all three of them
and i and i was able to take all the
things that my father has done for me
and
provided for me and view it as a good
and my dad's got plenty of shortcomings
i have plenty of shortcomings my kids
are getting older i'm laughing because
i'm like uh-oh
there's another side to this game
they're about to do it to me wait a
minute you know like and so
um i'm really proud of you that is
incredibly emotionally enlightening that
you can understand let me take what pops
did well
let me not take
what pops didn't do well and most people
are incapable of doing that and i think
your blind optimism on employees
is a kissing cousin to your ability to
take the good from your dad
and and try to build on it
um
i think that's a really big i just i i
wish every person that's listening here
can start the process of forgiving their
parents
on what they didn't do well
being pumped about the one and even if
it's one thing
you know maybe it's not even something
that they did maybe it's they gave you
pretty blue eyes and that was a good
factor in your life just being
appreciated for something
and then building forward
you my mom and dad [ __ ] me up is just
not an excuse for the rest of your life
right
it's really cool
yeah so cool so you you brought all of
that to the table as the young 20 year
old i have so many entrepreneurs as you
can imagine listening to this this is
why i want to talk about it
who are you now all these years later
and as you embark i'm probably hiring a
lot of people and obviously ryan is
probably going to be very involved i
don't know what you know you probably
have other responsibilities i'm not even
sure where you are in your investing
career like because is moonboard like
actually i'm just going to ask you is
this it like is what you do now
yeah you know the best things are you
you're passively involved in a bond
yeah true ventures were you know as a
partner at they they um have been very
cool about this whole thing i mean they
put they put some money into the company
so that's been great um and they've been
like
you gotta go yeah into proof yeah that
and they're like you know you need to
just go wrong with this and so
um you know the deals and stuff that i
would typically look at with thankfully
we have 50 plus people at true that i
can hand them off to yeah they're
amazing yeah so this is it this is
you're the ceo it's my focus right now
yeah that's right and so
who do you think you know what what do
you think's gonna be different this time
oh man a ton a ton i think that you know
in in terms of just
having spent had so much time in the gap
between when i started dig and then
where i am today um you know just the
well i'll give the probably the biggest
influence was when i joined google
and when i was inside of google and saw
how that machine worked
and you know and i i saw the the caliber
of talent that was around the table and
just the rigor and process
and execution uh that they're able to
pull off and
uh all those things i was like whoa wait
a second yeah yeah like i know why they
win you know it's it's like
these people are smart it's tight
they're going
it's smart that it's it's tight they're
going they um
you don't have to micromanage anyone
when you hire that caliber of an
employee they just they they go and they
run you know and they they can just
execute without you having to look over
their shoulder and that is a beautiful
thing when you can truly
let go of something
it's you know 13 years ago my
15 20 direct reports at vayner x
is now
allowing me to have the capacity to
double operate
right
100 i couldn't do the
friends years ago i couldn't something
would have fell the thing that's falling
now is brand garyvee which is a great
pleasure because i'm taking that energy
into the characters
um
but
that makes so much sense to me
real quick taste the wine have you had
the empathy cabernet yet i have not yet
but the elephant okay i'm first
yes you are a real wine guy these days
which makes me very happy and this is a
real wine inside that bottle so i'm
excited to get your vibes
that's beautiful dude what year is this
is it a 2019 wow
that's drinking quite well for how young
it is
this is amazing we couldn't put the
actual fruit that's in it because of
like reasons but it's a big deal line
it was super fun
i love that about you we talked about
this years ago where you you had this
idea
of so the thing that people don't know
about napa valley is that you have these
top-tier producers
that produce like the highest in
cabernet and for whatever reason
they have like a second blend or a cut
that just doesn't make it into their
main primary blend
and for anyone drinking it you'd be like
good god this is amazing wine it's like
the best ever right but they but they
make you sign an nda and then they'll
sell it off because they don't want
their brand confusion and delusion to
happen correct and so what you've done
here is you've clearly bought some good
juice and you're putting it in here yeah
i bet crazy but i guess i thought we
could have offline conversation about
this yes i will tell you but like let's
put it this way people got three times
the wine and it was expensive like 80
bucks so
i mean
do you
back to back to kind of like
people management
mental like
what do you think is
one of the things required today
emotionally for success that maybe isn't
talked about or
even if it's talked about is just kevin
wrote because we're all gonna have
different kevin rose's point of view of
like no no tenacity or ambition is under
unmisunderstood or patience like if i
said the emotional
framework rainbow
what gets you going in the way that like
empathy was clearly a big one for me and
then has now become much more pop
culturized like if i said to you
it actually let's let you know you're so
humble i just need this for you like for
i need this for me not for you
if i ask you kev you've really had some
career
like be nice to the kids listening it's
not about you giving roses everyone will
give roses to you it's your last name
like you know
what just as a teaching moment
what has allowed you to be sick in a
world where you can't memorize [ __ ] no
reading coverage or whatever like
what have you had why are you here why
is this working
why are me and all my a plus friends
this weekend texting k rose impressive
why
i think first and foremost would be
that
i have um
known
in that i'm going to fail at many many
many things
and so if you take a look at my track
record
i would say
half of the things that i have created
which have been raised a lot of money
have completely gone away and just
become nothing in fact still i still
miss pounce do you know me and aj talk
about pounds once a year
age i'm like bro i think you really
should have quit school like i told you
in the ceo of pounce
i kind of would have fake ceo that
behind the scenes and i think it could
have been twitter like we still we talk
about that
pounce is better than twitter at that
moment you built such a
burka
like ah man there was that was a really
good product
that was close you were stretched too
thin but it was close it was starting to
thin because i was trying to dig at the
same time and yeah it was just a lot of
the functionality that it exists today
in twitter uh a lot of that was was
first on pounce which is really really
cool but yeah yeah but i think the point
being is that
you know i i've met some entrepreneurs
they've been crushed by by missing on
their first their first at-bat you know
or their second and they've said you
know this didn't work well
if if you really believe it's in your
dna and some people aren't like this i
got a buddy
that um he works at reddit now and uh
you know he was early early written play
made some good money and literally goes
home at six o'clock at night and fires
up you know smoke some weed at night and
like for him that's the best life
possible right like he doesn't ever want
to be an entrepreneur and he's
completely content but if it's in your
dna and you know you feel it like i can
start something i have crazy ideas and
you want to go after it like you just
got to keep getting up out of bed every
single morning and it's never never this
is what i tell my team right now with
moon birds and everything that's going
on it's never up and to the right just
like non-stop it's going to be lumpy the
emotional ride of an entrepreneur is a
roller coaster with loop-de-loops and
all the crazy [ __ ] in it and it's going
to be you got to be ready for those days
as well so it's like that grit that has
to come out of you is real
and and it's it takes an emotional and
physical toll on your body and if you
but if you have that and you're ready
for that then you just get after it
every day you know you get up energized
and ready to build what you believe is
going to be the future
so tenacity is a real one
absolutely conviction conviction
tenacity
and also just not accepting
you know it's it's funny sometimes i'll
have an engineer that'll come to me and
be like ah that's that's tough that's
challenging i don't know if we can do
that and my response is always
listen
elon musk is landing rockets back onto
floating barges in the middle of the
ocean after they've come down from space
someone wrote that algorithm to land a
rocket on a floating barge that's moving
in the water like if we can do that yeah
we can do we can add that button
yeah
we can get the history of the watch on
who dinky right right exactly yeah we
could add that button or add that social
feed i'm like if that could be done we
can do it too so
you know i like history was what the one
class i did decent in
and it's usually been like 1900 to now
like very modern history
but occasionally when the pyramids come
up like when i'm in the middle east or i
see it on tv or
even in nft land i'm like on the pyramid
in the background like in the background
i literally do stop and think i'm like
these [ __ ]
a trillion years ago built this [ __ ]
thing with 0.0 machines in the world
it's crazy
i just i to your point are you a yes
person or no person
fascinating what's been the most uh
while i've got you
what's been the most surprising part
of the last
16 months let's call january 1 2021
the birth of the new generation nfts
what do you what does like completely
caught you off guard
well i mean
honestly it's um it's the different use
cases that are available to nfts i think
that it in i say this with absolute uh
truth when you attached util real world
utility to nfts i was like i remember
you hit me up and you're like dude i'm
doing this thing i was like oh [ __ ]
that's new that's exciting and like i i
think we're gonna see different
verticals of use cases for nfps appear
over the next year
and i love that i love that there is
there is um
well i'll give you one example since
we're talking about wine like there is
no reason why if i wanted to collect
empathy wine i would have to take this
as a shipment you could keep it in
perfect storage you could send it to me
as an nft
it could go up in value over time i
could trade it 10 times over with
multiple friends and then when the
person finally burns the nft at the end
to receive the bottle it has perfect
proven provenance we know where it came
from we know it was stored at the right
temperature like this is a no-brainer
right
well i literally if i was in the pigs
and shovels business i would be buying
up warehouses in the middle of nowhere
to have temperature controlled
security-based warehouses are about the
way data centers
popped up all over the world over the
next 20 years they're going to be
warehouses all over the country all over
the world
that are going to just hold [ __ ] like my
background right now
is going to be sitting my entire entire
sports card collection is going into the
middle of nowhere by the way no
different than tax havens for art in
morocco
it's not like the person's walking
around with their picasso
right right and so to your point from
issuing to collecting
i actually think the most exciting part
is nfts issued against physicals that
get held up in a mctile exchange or a
warehouse and get traded in perpetuity
to your point until you have to burn the
token to take it off the market to
actually get the physical right and then
then the the actual producer receives a
cut of those royalties every single time
it's resold which is amazing which is
the best because the person that
actually is the [ __ ] person
is the one winning economically that's
amazing and you cut out all the the the
fraud the faking the corkage issues like
all the storage
what you're very good at when we share
this is where our relationship started
you can't you're like me right like i'm
leading the witness but like it's insane
that even the people in it don't really
see how
forever changing this is gonna be
yeah well that that's great though
because that means it's early days and
we're right we're right in it we're
investing at the right time yeah exactly
for sure
do you think that you would this is
actually a great question for you given
to our providence did you ever think you
would get another at-bat like this the
way you did with web 2. obviously when
you did dig
you
and you were on tech you were on like
tech television right like the whole
school seth you watched him as a kid
the screen savers that's amazing
so you know you really saw it like i
know you so i'm gonna just tell it for
the audience you share what i share and
it's a [ __ ] thing which is you just
know
that the consumer you know the consumer
you really have that
really at the highest levels which is
why i've always
publicly given you so much daps and
you've just been such an intimate part
of my career um
did you even think about it did you even
like did it even crossed your mind that
there would be another era like what you
felt in your mid-20s
and a and then b
like how enjoyable has it been to get
the band back together i mean we've
interacted more in the last 14 months
than we did in the prior nine years
combined
like and mike lazaro and like like it's
been crazy for me this has been like
unbelievable truly the bands getting
back together again
thoughts on both those questions d a
very straightforward question do you
think because that's what this is this
is obviously a true did you think that
that would ever happen again in your
life
yeah i think that in my mind when you
talk about tech in general
these great
moments of transition is something like
completely different and new they happen
like at least they're cyclical but they
happen about every eight to fifteen
years and so you know you had web one
then web two was about four or five
years later
and then i would argue mobile was
probably the next big one after that
which was a handful of years later and
then now web threes is so you kind of
just sit there and you wonder am i going
to be too old to jump back in and maybe
it's a technology that doesn't even
apply to me that i'm not even excited
about like maybe it's like like
you know some type of farming like
revolution that happens where i'm just
like i'm not gonna go build a farm right
so
you might dude maybe you may be into
that you're into that [ __ ] but you know
it's like i'm a little hippy i do like
the
green out here
but i gotta say like when this happened
it's like you know like i've got a whole
thing of freaking wolverine number one
sitting over there i love collectibles
you know it's like i've always been you
you're the one that told me to go buy a
jordan back uh what was that about you
two years ago yeah you're like dude go
get a jordan rookie card they're like
it's like you called me up and i was
like i just really really
fractionalizing it remember they were
starting to fractionalize them i mean i
still think the fractionalization of
physicals in an nft world
has untapped value at scale
yeah the question is is the sec going to
see it as a security right which is
which is incredibly fair and like to me
like what's been fun about growing up in
the wine business was my whole business
life was based on there's going to be
regulation so i never get like i can't
wait for the sec to create correctly
like i don't i i paid
way i pay i happily paid an
uncomfortable amount of taxes yesterday
like i'm not looking to not pay my tax
i'm happy to be in america i was born in
ussr you know like i'm like i'll pay my
taxes i'll follow the rules
the problem is when things are moving so
fast the government's slower and i have
employees the government's trying to
figure it out i get it
right
yeah totally
what uh so okay so what surprised you
what else uh
just about this whole web 3 movement in
general
i would say let me actually finish the
last on which i think is fun
how did it feel when you realized it was
really really happening when do you when
do you say that you realized web3 was
becoming because you're a consumer guy
which is why i [ __ ] with you so heavy
like back to the intuition when do you
feel that you were like oh [ __ ]
like well i would say this
that happened before nfts that would
have been when d5 started happening and
i was realizing and i was watching the
mechanics behind the scenes that power
defy and how they could offer interest
that was like you know 10x higher than
your bank could with zero people and and
part of the reason why your bank can't
pay you the interest they want is wells
fargo has i don't know what it was 150
000 employees or something like some
outrageous number of overhead that they
have to pay for and so when you have
smart contracts and code that's powering
this stuff i was like oh of course
people are going to use this it's a
better product now it's harder to use
right now and all the rough edges
haven't been sanded down but that's when
you want to invest right that's when you
want to get in is when it's really
difficult to use and people are still
unsure and is this the future of course
digital currency is going to be the
future you tell me if you're if you if
you've got some land if i give gary his
own chuckle and say hey start a country
are you going to go buy printing presses
and [ __ ] no
you're going to start a digital currency
because it's the more modern thing to do
right like it's just everything's
everything's digital currency now who
the [ __ ] walking around
from the wine world and like 70 80 90
year olds and of course last couple
years so of course everyone needs 15
minutes of [ __ ] gary could i speak to
you for 15 minutes and you know they're
the ogs that i grew up with so i'm like
i got you you know johnny get him johnny
how's the family you know i haven't
talked to your 13th
and then they spend the entire 13
minutes [ __ ] on crypto
i was like why did we have this johnny
i've been talking 14 years since we
drank some wine in the wine business and
you called me for 14 minutes to [ __ ] on
crypto
and and i love it because i understand
the essence of it but i always end the
same way i'm like i kind of take the
punches and then i'm like johnny how
much cash do you have on you right now
i'm like you do know that your
grandfather said the same thing about
credit cards like that's where history's
a [ __ ] son of a [ __ ] go read the
quotes from people interviewed in
newspapers in the 60s about credit cards
oh dude i've got one better for you want
to hear something crazy listen to this
this is a true story
back in the day when they made the
transition to canvas paintings
there were haters that came out because
they said it's not permanent it's not on
the wall
it can be damaged and all everyone
discounted canvas paintings and thought
they were a cheaper knock off than
having something done permanent on a
wall or a structure
so how quick is how crazy is that isn't
it great because now what's happening
with nfts by the way i like like you
don't think people were sitting around
at dinner table saying [ __ ] these cars
johnny the horse outside is more than
enough
yeah my horse is so beautiful i can pet
my horse i can't pet my car control my
horse
like
like like a million things like like a
car might hit my horse like this right
right same [ __ ]
the one that was profound to me was i
bought the iphone the day it came out as
you did and everybody else that was in
our game
like people really thought the
blackberry was gonna win because the
buttons like i actually believed it i
was like the internet is on the iphone
right the internet
like i'm outside on the internet
it was slow as hell back then but it did
work it was slow as [ __ ] but you could
get to it it was profound remember like
walking around earth not knowing the
score of the game
yeah i mean i used to have to use
what did i use what was the one like the
palm palm had a phone and it was like
the worst browser you had little pins
looking at yeah yeah
holy [ __ ]
oh so kev okay so deep buy was it what
about on the consumer side
of nfts when did you have your nfp what
was your ah ha
for nft yeah i mean
so anybody that tells you they minted
crypto punks and knew what they were
doing is just full of it because i was
there i minted ten of them and i lost i
immediately forgot about them
kevin minted because they were free
in 2017 is that correct kev
uh whenever they came out yeah whenever
they come
yeah something like that 18
18 i think it's 17 yeah 17 right yeah
17.
yep you minted crypto punks in 2017.
let's just start with that
like the smartest friends i have in 2021
are like what the [ __ ] is so you a buddy
called me up and he was just like who my
friend patrick collins actually yeah it
was a childhood buddy i had yeah so
patrick called me up and he's like hey
he's like dude these things are cool
they're like on ethereum and like these
little punk rock characters i'm like i
like little punk rock characters and so
i just i just went and did that and then
i got 10 of them and i was like okay and
i immediately i thank god i had my my
one password and i had my my uh things
stored in there but i had kept him in a
wallet that was no longer supported when
i tried to revive them it wasn't
uh
it would have been december
um a little over a year ago year in
december 20
yeah exactly
right
when we talked was also december i think
maybe january but
had you already revived your punks when
we talked
i i just got them out i got them out i
finally got them working and i was like
oh crap i need to trade up to a zombie
right away because i want to get a
cooler one and so that's a very big
strength of yours i like having like 800
down here you like having two up there
and you're always right about that i
just like having 800 down here we
probably should have done all the above
my time
one of my friends has 300 v friends and
he's super sad because he's more like me
he has like 300 down here
and he doesn't have a panda he doesn't
have a black cat he doesn't have an
astronaut like so like he needed you in
his life because you went i remember i
remember vividly you saying dude you
need to get a zombie i'm like no i gotta
get 34 purple hats
like
i have a zombie and i have an ape so i
oh you bought that that's right oh my
god i'll never forget that day because i
was i was looking at doing you basically
priced me out because you you pumped
that one up and then then all the other
prices went up and i was like damn it
i'm i'm done
it's amazing how much i believe in
crypto punks long term i really believe
in provenance you know i really do yeah
i really think at the end of the day too
much has happened in 10 000 unique
characters in the last two years that
has pretty much solidified crypto punk
says this is who started that movement
this is what it is too many people that
own it i just i just think it's locked
and loaded
yeah i agree
there's i mean think about all the hat
tips of like the 3d glasses and all the
stuff that they like that is seen on
every pfe yeah what about what about the
fact that apes are incredibly important
in crypto bunks and board api club was
the next most important project that
came out in that era
so crazy
super cool um so what so what was your
aha you because we're starting there was
was you know punks were starting to rise
uh before that like
oh no no so when i've unlocked them they
were in december a thousand apiece in
december yeah then in january february
they started climbing um and then i saw
a bunch what what really opened my eyes
is how much tooling had been created so
opencv didn't exist back then so i saw
open c then i saw super rare and i was
like well wow there's marketplaces here
and i noticed some there was some
artists that were dropping
that were digitally native artists like
xcopy that only existed on the
blockchain
and i was like i was like whoa wait a
second this is the banksy for the
digital world and it's like and then our
blocks dropped and when our blocks
started to blow up i was like whoa
generative generative art is crazy i'm
like this is this is gonna catch fire
there's too many independent little
flames burning they're all gonna connect
and when the dots connect they're gonna
blow up and so i jumped in hard on our
blocks and started minting all the the
crazy early art block stuff
um but yeah it's just it's kind of that
you know you you get that gut feeling
like there's momentum here you we were
talking at the same time i remember we
were getting on these like calls you
would do you'd facetime me like late at
night and it was really late for you
because i think you were east coast
and it was just like these big groups of
people i would be thrown into the room
and you're like kev i just got some more
punks like tell us what else like we
need to talk about random stuff
the [ __ ] best i gotta go to my next
thing because i can't be rude i love you
i could do this a bunch thank you for
being on thanks for this conversation i
love you thanks for having me brother
appreciate it
and i'll see you in an hour or two or
whatever yeah sounds good love you see
ya